june shows coming up hollywood june 4th
i'm at the troubadour it's going to be a
really cool show june 24th i'm in des
moines iowa one night only june 25th
headed to omaha nebraska one night only
and back at brea california
june 30th one night only as well get
your tickets to those shows and all
shows at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media
every week i'm gonna throw out that
gratitude for you guys thank you so much
for watching this show thank you for
subscribing if you're not subscribed to
youtube it's a free way to help the show
hit that damn button it means everything
to us over here all right uh if you
gotta have more episodes i do a patreon
called the honeydew with y'all and i'm
highlighting the lowlights with y'all
and i gotta promise you y'all have not
let anybody down these stories are the
wildest [ __ ] i've ever i promise you
it's the wildest stories in comedy on
patreon all right it's five bucks a
month if you sign up for a year you get
over a month free there's no levels no
anything it's just five bucks sign up
for a year you're getting over a month
free and you're getting the honeydew a
day early ad-free at no additional cost
all right come out and see me on tour if
i'm in your town and you're free all
tickets are available ryan sickler.com
now that's the biz you know what we do
over here i always say we're
highlighting the low lights and these
are the stories behind the storytellers
very excited to have this guest
back
on the honeydew ladies and gentlemen
please welcome paul versey welcome back
thank you for having me man dude thank
you for being with your best it was i
wanna um
well
plug everything first and then i'm gonna
give you your your props okay well uh
guys if you're in tampa one of my
favorite clubs may 5th uh 6th and 7th i
will be at side splitters in tampa
florida love that place and had a great
time last time i was there so i want to
thank everybody who came out and hope
you guys come out again then i'm doing a
one-nighter in buffalo buffalo people
asked and i said all right i will come
to buffalo i'm doing one night may 26th
helium uh june 30th i'll be at the
american comedy company in san diego
california and for all other dates go to
paulversie.com
uh check out my podcast the versi effect
which i do by myself well half the time
by myself half the time with a guest and
the other podcast i co-host with bill
burke called anything better get my
youtube channel you could subscribe to
my youtube channel and my new special
will be on a major platform i thought i
was going to be able to announce it here
i would have loved to but it will be
coming out later this spring early
summer this year on a major platform and
i will announce that on my social medias
which is paul virzi v-i-r-z-i
dude profesh profess you spit it all out
yeah the same thing just saying that
you got your [ __ ] together you know how
many first rodeos don't come in here and
then sit there i don't know where that
well i don't know where i'm at what's my
website he's [ __ ] what's up
what's your name [ __ ]
what's my website where am i
[ __ ] that's so funny congrats on the
special thank you man um thank you for
being back we were talking before the
the show and i i said uh literally up
until the harlem williams episode you
were the first person to come in and
talk about
losing a pet yeah man and i was very um
look man you look i'm gonna say you guys
are the greatest [ __ ] fans in comedy
and i was pleasantly surprised to see
how much
and how well it was received i mean and
you said you're still getting love i
wanna i wanna i wanna take the
opportunity to say to to you and the the
listeners of the honeydew i was never
more honestly like
touched by the amount of of people that
reached out about the depression that i
went through in 2016 that story i told
and then
having my cat give me that look and
being with him for 16 years and he was
my wife's gift at her 26th birthday and
this big beautiful cat i had to take to
get put down and
dude i got letters from your listeners
from all over the [ __ ] world to this
day someone's like dude that honeydew
about my depression made me feel okay
about my depression and uh i'm a fan i
have people going i'm a fan for life
because of that episode so so thank you
thank the listeners uh like i said i
mean i've done a bunch of podcasts and
i've never ever
had a thing where like i could tell that
i touch people which also touched me so
it was really [ __ ] dope man yeah it
really was i i when you talked about i
was like this is interesting because you
know i've had a few dogs over my life
got a new one now and i just we were
just talking about like they just
they're part of your family you have
them all those years and there's
routines and habits they have you know
where they like to hide where they like
to sleep i was telling you i go to my
freezer and i'll go to get ice my dog
loves ice she's right at my i don't even
i just i now i do a game where i'm like
let me look down boom right there just
looking at me and i'm like yeah and you
missed that after yeah cause that's your
routine like the animal becomes your
routine your life and and i was saying
this to somebody you know if the other
day if you don't like animals like if
you don't i'm not saying you have to
like be an animal like have them yeah
but if you just are like [ __ ] adam
there's you're a piece of [ __ ] there's
something
right
you know what i mean like all this thing
wants is like to be kind of loved and
unconditional love this thing wants to
give and dude i don't i don't uh when i
was 13 years old this is not what i'm
gonna talk about when i was 13 years old
my dad got me a pellet gun for my
birthday my mother my parents got had a
brutal divorce and i think my mom was
not happy and my dad was like yeah get
him a gun like maybe the [ __ ] dick he
got me a gun to dig at her and [ __ ] and
i [ __ ] went outside i just started
[ __ ] put the co2 i just start
shooting the birds and [ __ ] yeah you
know what i mean me too and there's this
like beautiful bird and i shot this
thing and it landed by my feet and i
just saw it gasping for it's like a blue
jay where there's like gasping for air
and i just obviously i put out some
misery i cried like a f i cried like a
[ __ ] dude i was eight eighth grade and
i'm crying like a [ __ ] and i just like
[ __ ] put the gun i don't want this
thing i can't
you know and then you hear when these
people like even like wild boars which
are like a problem i guess yeah but if i
shot something and i heard make like
like they make noises
and then they they're like and then
they're like it's like in the movies
where they're [ __ ] trying i love your
invitation of a dying bore right now
yeah but it's just yeah it's just the
thing
it's just like a fat picture i picture a
and the thing is you put that thing in
that position yeah [ __ ] that dude like
life is too
i'm gonna [ __ ]
you yeah so but there are certain dudes
that are like up
and like yeah that's a whole other dude
it is that's a whole lot of dude
my brother's that dude oh your brother's
entity oh my brother used to do that
[ __ ] all the time but one of my
favorites was uh this [ __ ] shot
a woodpecker from our deck it was it was
driving us nothing
you know they sound like a machine yeah
and he went and got his bb gun and had
we had to scope on a little daisy 880.
it was a pellet and bb gun and yeah
and you just see that bird dropping like
you [ __ ] got it so we go down there
and he's like yeah look at this
[ __ ] this my brother and so it's
woodpecker like this not one of those uh
not that like woody woodpeckers that tom
segura killed not the endangered species
tom segor shot and killed this is a
little guy like this big
and my brother picks it up and that
little [ __ ] woodpecker shook it
off and liz lit his hand up
[ __ ] up and he threw it on the ground
that's what i knew that was at the end
of that woodpecker he threw that thing
on the ground
i just it [ __ ] got oh oh it lit them
up they [ __ ] this whole thing you know
what it's good for him though to get
those last licks
and then this is what i laughed about
that my brother was so pissed off
he's got his hand all right that's all
[ __ ] him up man it [ __ ] up yeah so
he shot it and killed the thing right
and then he takes the string of his
hoodie out and he ties the [ __ ]
woodpecker up like what are you sending
a message to the woods
he hung it okay the next day we go back
it's gone strings there and there's all
these little like fox prints under it
and i'm laughing because i'm saying
could you imagine being a fox
and just walking through the woods and
you got you you'd be like you gotta be
bullshitting right now there's a [ __ ]
woodpecker out of me yeah yeah and then
like there's somewhere in the animal
world there's an old asp like it was
hanging in a tree
it was hanging by a string at a tree
like oh good grip
that's great he did it
he [ __ ] his hand though there is a
there is a certain there is a certain
type of dude that's like like that just
like no we're going to get jerky and
[ __ ] and then they're just like like but
also they got to gut him
dad was one of those [ __ ] just slice
them down take the organ and then hang
them upside down
and act like a i got pictures of deers
hanging deer hanging off our deck all
gutted open and drying out and stuff and
then my dad got us he got a starter
shotgun yeah to see if we want to go
like hunt pheasant whatever you know and
we just played sports all the time we're
like man we're just not into it like
it's not my thing i don't want to go
hunt deer and shoot plus if you're
hunting and you're doing it right yeah
the one thing i hated doing was getting
up early and you are getting up early
and you're going out there and you're
doing if you're doing it right you're
sitting there you're quiet i don't want
to do that [ __ ]
i'll fish talk laugh i don't want to go
hunting be quiet to try to stalk
something in the woods yeah get out of
my warm ass bed so we played sports and
then my dad was like
he was done like i think he hunted with
his buddies and he liked it but once we
were like nah we'd rather play sports
than hunt he was like cool and that was
it never hunted and these dudes will sit
up in a stand for seven hours quiet yeah
and like you know be like i'm enjoying
it i'm like i you know i can't yeah i
don't want to be on like a jet blue with
entertainment i love my family you know
what i mean yeah yeah you know what i
mean that's those [ __ ] like no
no no my dad's a trip because my dad's
just my dad is gaudy you know i mean i
don't know if i've ever talked about my
dad my dad's like you know chains and my
dad's got my dad wear like a fur coat to
go get a slice you know and uh he said
my aunt my my aunt my aunt lived and i'm
not even joking i believe i just saw
this lady in this badass blue fur last
night and i was like i [ __ ] i want
that yeah it looks so good i was like
man i want to wear it my dad is always
like a man needs to have a watch shoes
that's what you said
all that that's who that's who my dad is
gaudy right so my aunt lives in denver
colorado and my dad called her up he's
like hey he goes can i hunt ram
rape
cause he goes i want a [ __ ] ram head
on my wall and she goes what
she goes i think that's illegal he goes
i swear to god make some calls
let's see if we could go in the
mountains i'll bring this shotgun we'll
[ __ ] get a ram and he was like and he
was all like upset and confused that
they couldn't he goes yeah i don't
understand it's like dad they're like in
date like nobody you don't eat ram no
one's eating ram maybe they are
somewhere somebody yeah the ram head is
probably like a dope thing but like
that's like that's some cruel [ __ ]
um
all right so let's talk about well
you want to talk about
uh a cancer scare is that right
yeah so because i have one as well and i
know these people are sick of hearing it
but i'll tell you quickly what about
mine but i want to hear yours first
so i was probably
um
well i'll start with this in 1997
okay i was i was not a good high school
student i was very resp like respectful
for my teachers and they liked me
but i was like you know a distracted kid
you know i had my parents got divorced
when i was young i would lash out i
would act out do stupid [ __ ] get
arrested drink just you got arrested oh
yeah i got arrested like four times just
four times yeah just dumb [ __ ] like a
one was it one was a d dwi
one was um you know i was but pissing in
public at oneonta my friends went to
college i you know i got a breast i got
putting a hold himself for that uh i got
arrested for the you know naked and i
don't know if i got arrested for getting
naked in the emergency room and i ran
down looking for my friend naked my dick
it was bad
wait hold on you ain't gonna jump over
that i don't think you told that story
all right well what do you mean all
right i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna tell
you this is a [ __ ] doozy i didn't
play i'm gonna tell you
um i never had it i never out no
alcoholic or alcoholism but like i was
the dude that when i when i go i [ __ ]
like if i go in heart you know we were
in college and i was it got to the point
where i was like take beer out of that
funnel and put [ __ ] absolute in that
[ __ ] thing yeah and we put absolute
and then a scoop of [ __ ] iced tea mix
and just [ __ ] down the chute dude
right
so beer bong and vodka oh dude yeah dude
it was yeah
yeah so we lived downtown by the way i
went away i went away where to to uh
community college i went away
okay yeah i'm glad you said a way to
communicate
yeah like i went like three hours near
syracuse to go to this [ __ ] school
right there and is it a campus or you
live right off campus there's a there's
a campus but we me and my friends that
that went to high school together we got
a house downtown we got we got an
apartment we'll get a house okay and all
the houses the same guy had all the real
estate these two brothers and all the
houses were different colors so there
was a blue house there was a grey house
it was yes we were in a blue house
and um
there was a group of girls that lived at
like a house near us and they were like
it was actually a big school for soccer
so they always wanted to [ __ ] with the
soccer and lacrosse kids and never us we
were just these kids from new york who
wanted to party and whatever
but one night we're [ __ ] chilling out
we're partying and there was no soccer
kids and they were into hanging with us
okay
um this was the night
i s we i think i believe this was the
night we found out that um i think this
was the night it was around the same
time that farley died okay because i
remember seeing it scroll across the
bottom or whatever and they were playing
darts and we're having a good time and
this chick that was always into soccer
is kind of like into us and like
everybody is like oh man they're into
they're actually into the new york guys
this is great so one of my buddies goes
to our apartment to get some to get some
weed okay
and
and all of a sudden it starts getting
late we're having a good time um it's
it's the time of the party where it's
like you're not fully drunk but it's
coming
and everybody's chilling music is on
it's like the heart of the party yeah
you know the hard part it's like the
meter is right in the middle and it's
about to right
and my other roommate comes in kicks
almost kicks the door down and goes dude
we gotta go dude chad just broke his
finger running up the stairs and i go
what i got how the [ __ ] did he up the
stair who breaks their finger going
upstairs he didn't he was just running
in this kid so i'm like i gave the look
like no dude
look at this we can't it's a finger and
he goes dude it's broken bad it's like
really fractured we gotta go to the
hospital dude i'm i gotta i'm staying
so you know i'm just [ __ ] chilling
darts everything
five minutes later my buddy chad with a
broken finger comes in he goes you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you're gonna stay
for some [ __ ] you're gonna stay here
just like lose you ain't a friend
[ __ ] and i'm just gonna and i'm going
dude dude what not it's [ __ ] this is
a he goes this is and i'm and then so
i'm so drunk and i feel better all right
i'm telling i'll be back it's like three
in the morning i'll be back i'll be back
i'll be back
i'll be there by the way by the way i
want you to notice something i had no
plans on telling the story everything
i'm telling you in this story is 100
true 100 true everything down to every
detail
so
i go i'll be back don't you guys be up
so we're in the car and i'm in the back
my buddy jb rest his soul he's driving
my buddy chad with the with the broken
finger and i'm sitting in the back and
it's a it's a quiet blizzard okay
blizzard it's coming down but it's that
nice quiet [ __ ] i love that and i'm
looking so silent it was silent and we
couldn't go too fast and we're going to
the hospital uh in in little falls new
york i'm sure somebody will know this
story this is and and i'm looking around
and the the drunkness starts to hit i'm
in the back and like the snow is looking
different i'm seeing trails of [ __ ] i
might have been high i was it just i'm i
have no business being out
and we get to the emergency room and i'm
starting to get angry that i'm not at
the party right and they bring chad in
to get his finger wrapped and me and my
boy jb are sitting in the [ __ ] we're
sitting in an emergency room waiting
room and i just start going [ __ ] this
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] are you gonna
[ __ ]
break your finger going up so i should
be at this part i start talking to
myself i go into the bathroom and i
start pissing all over the bathroom
right then i start ripping magazines and
i start throwing it right
so he goes oh no no i missed one part
when we were walking and i jumped on the
hood of an ambulance and actually
yeah i acted like i was in die hard i go
yo yo look look and i like held on now
you're going it's
dude you can't you can't we can't do
that come on come in come so like he got
me off the thing and i go in i start
kind of pissing in the toilet then out
of the toilet and then i start ripping
magazines and i start throwing magazines
and i'm angry and my buddies kind of
just laughing but paul you got to stop
you got to stop
head to god i go you know what
[ __ ] it
i get stark naked what i get naked and i
start running i'ma stop you for a second
are you a guy that gets naked had you
ever done anything in high school i used
to be the guy that would get naked at a
party sometimes yeah you know what it is
right yeah like i used to like steal
imaginary second like drunken like in
the rain
yeah yeah yeah i had that friend too
just streaked the party
i'm in a waiting room in the emergency
room in little falls new york and i got
naked how many people are interested
is me my buddy maybe someone else but
nurses were all around
oh yeah there was like a handful of
nurses and i just start running
i'm naked and i start running down
popping and looking for my friend and i
[ __ ] pop in a room and i see my buddy
chad and he did that delay where he goes
wait dude what the [ __ ]
and i go come on we're dancing and i
started making my you know i'm doing the
whole [ __ ] thing and i come on the
nurse wants to dance with me and i go up
to the nurse and i start trying to dance
naked naked dude and she's going
somebody
somebody call the cops somebody somebody
call the cops and my buddy's going dude
get my butt buddy jimmy's get your [ __ ]
closer i gotta go get him out here my
buddy chad who's he forgot his finger
was broken he's laughing so hard he
can't believe what he's seeing right
he can't believe it so i'm going come on
she's dancing and like i tried to like i
didn't like grab her hips but i did the
thing where i was like let's she's like
somebody call the cops somebody call the
cops right
so i grab my [ __ ] i run out i get
dressed my buddy is like we're out of
here we're gonna be in the part of the
chill we're gonna be in the parking lot
of this [ __ ] place now it's still
snowing okay and i put my things on i
put my my everything belt buckler back
on and we're in the car and we're
sitting there and jb just goes jb just
arrested so he lost his life
unfortunately and he goes uh he goes
yo you want to do donuts
and i go yeah
yeah
yeah no i'm [ __ ] i'm a hammer of
course and he starts whipping around
he's got a nissan 300 and he starts
whipping around this parking lot and all
of a sudden we see blue and red lights
you're doing this in the parking lot of
a hospital almost hitting the [ __ ]
poles
and dude i was so hammered i was so
hammered my memory that was which one of
you pieces of [ __ ] got naked in this
hospital i swear to god i go someone got
a naked [ __ ] disrespect who the [ __ ]
and he goes he goes i bet you it was you
you piece of [ __ ]
arrests us we get arrested for i got
like public whatever that whatever the
charge was gets arrested my buddy goes
dude i'm getting arrested for laughing
at you i'm getting i'm being arrested
i'm getting arrested for for laughing at
you he's like you're lucky i had bail
money to like so our bail was like
whatever 100 something bucks and then we
show up to court
the courtroom's packed like a movie it
was like it was like it was like a
[ __ ] it was like a [ __ ] whatever
time to kill it was [ __ ]
he was waiting for [ __ ] matthew
mcconaughey's final
and i'm nervous dude and there's a big
bailiff
i swear to god it's a big bailiff
sitting there and i'm nervous dude and
he's going through it he goes uh mr
verzi please step to the you know and i
step up and he goes
okay he looks he's looking at the thing
and he's going okay
so
i see uh mr have a report here that says
mr verzi exposed his bare buttocks in
the little falls emergency room
when asked why are you naked
mr verzi's reply was my belt buckle came
undone
and i swear to god the bailiff just goes
dude the bailiff the bailiff broke he
just goes oh
and he just goes mr version he goes if
you're ever if i ever catch you doing
this in my town again i'm gonna throw
you in jail for 30 days and i said your
honor you'll never see me again
and that was it [ __ ] yeah that's the
truth that's a great [ __ ] story dude
100 true man your friend though a little
bit of a [ __ ] with that finger she'll
let you stay over there i'm glad we got
the story out of it yeah man i snapped
my ankle tendons and everything my
brother barely slowed down
in the front of the hospital i was like
get out and they just left my ass they
didn't come in with me and all that [ __ ]
yeah yeah i think it was more i think it
was more like yo if we have to leave you
after yeah that's exactly what it was if
we're not getting posted you ain't
getting fuzzy
but what led us there what led us there
because uh well we were talking about
being in the hospital you i had a scare
yes yes so so anyway um i wasn't a good
student in in school because but when i
wanted to be i was so like i had a
teacher one time go hey man you don't
belong in this english class you belong
your essays are really good don't
embarrass me i'm gonna put you in this
good class and i went from like a c
student in the lower english to a b-plus
student in a higher english so she
believed in me and and that that's the
type of student i was but so towards the
end of high school i needed to like i
was getting close like am i going to
graduate in four years and i wanted to
one day my mother i'm sorry were you
worried you it would take longer i was
worried that i was i was worried that
like with my grades like i didn't want
to be somebody to go i didn't want to go
to summer i definitely didn't want to do
five years but i didn't want to go i
didn't want to go to summer school which
i never had to thank god i ended up
passing and getting through it but one
day as a senior i hear my mother from
the bedroom i hear either what is
hysterical crying or hysterical laughing
and uh unfortunately it wasn't the
latter i go in and my mom is just like
pale and she's not really she's not
really feeling good and and uh come to
find she's like i was like i'll stay
home from school she's like no go to
school and
she's i didn't like school i'll stay you
know she was like she's like no go to
school like fourth period gym they were
like listen your mother's being rushed
to the hospital i don't want to scare
you i go home it's like that same
morning that same day and i see true i
pull up my street and i see troopers and
i see [ __ ] ambulance like a movie
dude like and they're all in my house
and my mom's best friend who was there
at the time i was like she's all right
she's in there i pulled my mom my mom
looked bad and my mom goes oh you want
me to come in the ambulance she goes no
she goes i don't want him in the
ambulance with me uh i was like all
right i'm gonna go to my job and tell
him i can't work because i worked at a
pizzeria so i'm gonna go to the pizzeria
tom i can't work today i'm gonna come
right up to the hospital found out my
mother like threw up so much blood in
the hot in the in the ambulance like
like they said like 40 of her blood she
was just whoa yeah dude she was like
gonna she gets to the hospital they ask
her if she wants a priest or a [ __ ]
that's where she's just hemorrhaging so
then they [ __ ] up and said it might
have been like a bleeding ulcer it was a
tumor she had a tumor in her stomach and
it was a very long story short
it was a very rare cancer
and um
she was after four surgeries taking it
out and being cancer-free you can't do
any more surgeries right like they take
it out cancer-free all of a sudden
something's growing back cut it i'd take
it out you can't after so many times so
then they find little
spots all over my mother's liver and my
mom's in like stage four now and it's
really really bad
and two months before my mother's last
relapse the dana-farber institute in
boston came out with a test drug for
people with leukemia my mother didn't
have leukemia but it was working on what
my mother had
they do a test study of 100 people
it works on like
like 26 of them like really well my
mother's one of them then it dwindles
down to 10 and my mother's one of them
really okay my mother is alive today
after stage four stage four cancer a
test drug
uh saved my mother's life this doctor
dimitri shout out to him shout out to
the dana farmers student in boston save
my mother's life this is you said 97 her
first cancer was 97 when the initial
tumor they took it out then a couple
years later and then when it started to
spread a few years later so you're
talking like close to
you're talking almost 25 years and my
mother's here she got to see weddings
and grandkids and you know the the
medicine beats her up a little bit it
beats up her immune system but my mother
is like all the cancer is kind of dead
or like not like has completely grown
you know you're not growing but like
almost like dormant thank god knock on
wood
my mom is now my mom is 71.
since her late 40s yes so so yeah and
just so
so now
i'm a hypochondriac and i think part of
that played a part okay
so i like passive doctors
you know you know that seinfeld episode
oh you're nuts
get out of here i wanna and my doctor
knows that i want a doctor look at me
i'm gonna get the [ __ ] out of here man
you know so this one
this little stretch of time i had this
really weird abdominal issue like by by
where my appendix is right
and but it was weird it was this awkward
ache it was really weird man and a
couple days i'm going this is an and i'm
going i just need to go to the doctor so
i go to the doctor and my doctor knows
my past knows my mother
and he goes let me let me see if this is
your appendix it's gonna hurt when i
push it he goes but when i let go it's
gonna hurt more
okay and he pushes it and it hurts and
he lets go and it doesn't hurt at all
and he's like i see that he's like he's
like perplexing he's like what the [ __ ]
what so he's trying to do it he's and
and he's like
all right you know hold on a second and
he walks out of the room and halfway out
of the room he goes you know what paul
he goes i gotta i'm gonna just send you
the emergency room and i want them to
take blood because something's not right
and i that was and and that's so and i
go what and he goes yeah something's not
so i go home and my mom goes what's
wrong they want me to go to hospital
right now and she goes my mom thought i
was [ __ ] with her because she knows
that i get nervous about she like i go
normal he said to go up there and and to
go check
so she's [ __ ] she's been through all
her [ __ ] yeah and i know where her where
her mind went i get to the hospital they
make me drink this [ __ ] water that
tastes like some chocolate [ __ ]
and i'm drinking it and they they go on
a skin and they go
we found them oh we found a mass there
[ __ ] man i'm reliving this we found a
mass there and i'm going okay and we
want to go to surgery tonight tonight
tonight
so my mother comes in and my mother was
trying to play cool mother but i could
tell my mother was on some like
this was [ __ ] up so
she's like it's alright i'm telling him
i call my brother i'm dude i'm going to
surgery like i'm going to surgery at
midnight and they're like what i go yeah
they did all tests all day there's some
mask there they don't know what it is
i'm going to surgery tonight and now i'm
like [ __ ] dude they're wheeling me in
they're putting [ __ ] on my head i'm just
like waiting there
and um i go in for the surgery
and i remember waking up i went in
nervous too and i and and this big
abdominal thing you know a big scar i
have
and not huge but you know um and
i wake up and i never forget i come out
of this [ __ ] and i come out and i'm
looking up and my mother goes
it's done they took it out it took it's
you know it's done and then she didn't
say anything else
and i'm going what and i'm coming too
and i go what's up what happened
well they found something that that
they're going to test and dude it was
like all right i got to see it i didn't
get to see no
um but i found out that they told my
mother
[ __ ] dude i'm reliving this they told my
mother we hadn't seen anything like this
before like there's an effect there's
something like we haven't seen and it's
the same thing they told her
so she so and and i and i kind of got
wind of that so i'm laying in the
hospital and i'm like look you need to
be here after that surgery for at least
four days okay
and we're gonna do biopsy on this thing
and test this thing
and dude i'm laying there oh every
second has got to be excruciating every
[ __ ] second okay
and uh and then you're thinking this
could be your last
days and you don't even know what to
[ __ ] do with these minutes right now
and and i'm i'm yeah man and i i've
never talked about it this detail
and i had about two years in the comedy
i was doing the urban circuit black
rooms and i was doing some eight mile
[ __ ] and i was killing i was doing well
and i remember like i would i would like
at night i would talk to god i would be
like look man like because this is when
i knew that it was just more than like
bringer shows and open mics this is like
this got to a point where i was like
even though it was only like two and a
half years three maybe three at the time
it was still like like i was doing [ __ ]
i was like i was making i was like three
and a half yeah i think now that i think
about three to three and a half years in
and i was like doing contests and doing
things and i was like making a little
bit of noise in the new york scene for a
guy that's not quite in the clubs yet if
that makes sense yes
and i remember being like if you can
just get me through this i just want to
get through this i would do i was
literally like laying i got like a
morphine drip every once in a while with
pain but i remember and i'd watch tv at
night and i was alone at night my mother
would be there every morning that's what
i want to ask who was allowed to come
see you so it was literally like
everybody else my parents divorced my
father was away like so so um
and i didn't really my father and i
relationship at the time it was like
we're always cool but he was just like
from afar loving me but it was like my
mother was there every morning and
that's what it was and every morning i
woke up she was at the edge of the bed
but we you know you know and not not
that i'm something like big religious
but i you know i was praying hey man i
just whatever i
whatev if i can get through this i'm
gonna make the best of this i'm gonna
make the best of comedy i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna take comedy as far as i
could take it in my life if i get
through this you know and this is
[ __ ]
20 years ago i'm going you know i just
need i i want to you know get through
this and i would watch tv at night but
then i would there were hours alone the
hours alone would be when my mom would
kiss me goodbye like after like the
dinner time early evening sun going down
and i'd be in the hospital alone and i
would give visitors but i was alone dude
and i was like
if this is can't if this is cancer then
my mom had it
um you know my friend
my friend in the hospital that i said
that passed away he died from cancer and
his mom had cancer two years before him
so there was all around me and and and
now they're looking at this thing
and how big was it do you remember i
think when they said they took it out
but what it was was so so so day
i remember there was a couple
embarrassing things that happened like
the nurse was always nice so she had to
take the catheter i'm addicted
but yeah and like you know and
hearing it yeah and you know your dick
is [ __ ] baby dick when she's coming
in and you want to be like hey just so
you know
oh
yeah and she's like i gotta pull it out
you know he pulled it out i'm gonna tell
this is this is the one of the funniest
things that has ever happened well i'll
get to the story let me finish the story
now i gotta tell you one of the funniest
things that happened with my neighbor in
the hospital who came in hospital
because one of the first things i've
ever seen
so um
every day my mother was there and the
doctor now one thing that was good was
the day before we were gonna get the
main biopsy results
the doctor came in and kind of gave an
indication which is like
as legal as he can do it he gave an
indication oh the preliminary things
don't look so look alright or something
he did something that my last night
there alone gave me like watching tv i
had a little bit of hope
i had a little bit of hope you know and
and i'm sitting there i'm like oh my god
when i wake up tomorrow they're coming
in with tests to tell me like you know
what they're doing a biopsy they're
looking at this thing
and uh isn't it [ __ ] crazy that
at that point in time
somebody already looked at your [ __ ] and
some
human out there had all the answers yeah
that you're laying in that bed dying to
[ __ ] know yeah so i'm absolutely good
some guys could have just been like jet
skiing in miami we'll tell them monday a
hundred guys got a [ __ ] pina colada
i'm sitting here
i got a [ __ ] catheter in my dick
[ __ ] listen to the flow riders
spinning out going to eating sushi and
[ __ ] on a yacht
with your results
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
one of the greatest [ __ ] surgeons is
just [ __ ] whipping down right
oh god that's the best
so
if you have multiple credit card
balances each month and are only paying
the minimums barely making a dent in
your credit card debt it can be
discouraging upstart can help you pay
off your existing debt quickly so you
can feel like you're financially getting
ahead so whether you're paying off your
credit cards or
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over a million
people have used upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date upstart knows you're more
than just your credit score so rather
than looking at your credit score alone
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income your employment and
other information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan you can check your rate
without impacting your credit score in
just five minutes for loans between 1
000 all the way up to 50 000 and you can
even receive your funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com honeydew that's
u-p-s-t-a-r-t
dot com slash honeydew don't forget to
use my url to let them know i sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
honeydew this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp life is full of twists and
turns stress changes grief moments of
growth and moments where we feel like
we're taking a few steps back and it's
important to show up for yourself
through all the struggles that life can
bring better help online therapy is here
to for the twists and turns and we'll
assess your needs and can match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
in less than 48 hours it's not a crisis
line it's not self-help it's
professional therapy done securely
online and the service is available for
clients worldwide you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your therapist you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions so you won't
ever have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room as with traditional therapy
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available visit
betterhelp.com honeydew that's better
help and join the over 2 million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help they're
recruiting additional therapists in all
50 states special offer for the honeydew
listeners you're going to get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
honeydew that's betterhelp.com
honeydew for 10 off your first month now
let's get back to the do so the last day
i i so so that last night i had a little
hope that's so funny you said that well
so the last day i had a little hope so i
wake up and and for the first time out
of all the days my mother's not there
for she wasn't sitting there every day i
woke up she was already at the edge of
the bed sitting i wake up day to find
out day five
and i'm going my mom's not here she's
probably like right down the hall coming
but she wasn't there and i go oh my god
this is a day like 30 no less than 30
minutes later uh
no five minutes later my mom comes in
hey sweetie how you doing it's gonna be
fun no matter what it is it's gonna be
fine my mom was you know dopes like
whatever you know but she went through
so much [ __ ] so she's like whatever it
is you're not gonna tell her stage four
[ __ ] cancer yeah it's not gonna be
okay yeah yeah and uh she she says um
it'll be fine whatever it is and then
like half hour later me and my mom are
having a good conversation two doctors
walk in a [ __ ] manila folder and a
piece of nothing was more important in
my [ __ ] life than that piece of paper
that this [ __ ]
surgeon was
i mean that i mean walking down the
hallway had an answer right right he
went from the jet skis to the soda
machine
it's [ __ ] dr pip saying get up this
goddamn machine gets stuck every time i
[ __ ] you know
just down here what's going on with me
so uh
so he comes in and he goes uh i want you
he smiled and he looked at me and he
smiled and right when he looked at me i
kind of i kind of got a good indication
he goes
we did a biopsy on this thing five times
to check it and he says um
what it is is you have a a diver ticket
there's something called diverticulosis
usually older men get it on their left
side i had what diverticulos says it's a
little canal
in like the intestines that things can
get stuck in okay that's why people with
diverticulosis cannot eat seeds
you can't eat seeds you can't eat
popcorn all those things that have the
things that could stick or a seed can
get in there and [ __ ] it up and clog it
so i was i was born
my thing was on the right which is rare
something got stuck in there got
infected they took it out they also did
take out they were like hey we were
there we took out the appendix just
because we they just took out my
appendix because it was like it was
there so they took out my appendix they
took out this infection which was a
diverticulosis like really flare-up of a
very certain specific area
they told me i would be all right he did
say you got to watch what you eat this
could flare up again later in your life
found out now come to find out my father
has diverticula so he can't eat things
like that but mine just happened to be
on the right side uh they taped me up
and a day later i said ma can i go to uh
the yankee game and she was like paul
you you're gonna be [ __ ] leaking
yankees so we but i went with my brother
and it was never
it was one of
it was it was literally the first real
life second chance that i really like i
felt like i had and so when any time
somebody says to me
anything about like because somebody
didn't get the news i got right somebody
didn't get that news so how dare i not
even here to tell that story right so
how dare i not do anything i want to do
how dare i you know anything that
somebody wishes that could get out of
that [ __ ] hospital bed and do um so
so that one that one really really uh
bothered me but one of the funniest
parts about this story is
an older man
ryan i don't even know if i could tell
you this because you're to fly off that
[ __ ]
dude
an older man is at the curtain you know
next to me and day three of this ordeal
i hear hey young man i go yeah he goes
yeah they got you and we just talking
where they get to the food how's the
freeze just talking to me right and he
just goes yeah i got i'm stuck here man
and i'm going yeah he goes yeah
he goes you seem like a nice kid you'll
be all right this and that he goes yeah
he goes i can't leave until my testicle
unswells
and i go i go what
he goes yeah i got this thing
he goes yeah i got this thing with one
of my testicles you know it blew out oh
it blew out he goes he goes i got one of
my testicles really swollen i can't let
me leave the hospital until he goes it
happened once before he goes this you
know and i'm going all right like i'm
just trying to now i don't know if he's
[ __ ] up right right you know like i
don't he could be he could be all
[ __ ] crazy
all i know is he's older and he's my
neighbor and he's trying to be friends
with me and he's very nice and he said
something like oh i see the people
coming to visit you that's nice like he
was nice but he's saying this so a day
and a half me and this guy talk more
hand to god
he go i come out of the bathroom he goes
come here you got to look at this thing
ziggler i swear to you did you go every
day yeah
i swear to you holy on anything holy
this man opens his thing his [ __ ] if
my memory is correct his left testicle
looked like a legit softball get the
[ __ ] out that big it looked like it was
and it looked and i just go and i just i
couldn't yeah that is
between baseball and salt like it was
probably
it was probably it was probably between
the guy would have loved it if it was a
pool ball
god he would have loved it if it was a
pool ball this was between major league
baseball and and legit softball and i i
couldn't look long but i saw like you
know you see like the [ __ ] purpley
[ __ ] and he's just like yeah so this
thing's gotta go down and i'm like i'm
like yes the [ __ ] it does i wouldn't let
you i wouldn't let you forget
forget leaving the hospital i wouldn't
let you insist you shouldn't be home
like dude
i i can't
like ryan i can't believe it's possible
what i saw i can't believe a testicle
could blow out tonight yeah it's scary
i'm going like what like what's in that
what why this end his first rodeo and
he's going yeah i think he was acting
like here we go again so he had some
clear testicle [ __ ] but um i'll never
forget seeing that and me and my mom had
a good laugh because i told her and it
was actually it eased me yeah it eased
me a little bit even though it was so
ridiculous like even with everything
going on i'm like dude i'm like come
here
you guys this guy's got a ball like you
have never seen before and and that kind
of loosened it up but he was very nice
and he was happy for me when i left but
um
that changed my life and the reason that
the reason that changed my life is
because i i learned a lot at 23 or
however i was at the time i learned a
lot that like
the what we said before somebody's not
getting that news
and and and somebody gets the bad news
there and they can't go on with the
comedy career and live their dream like
i've been able to
and i've also now have ammunition for my
children when i tell them things and
they say that they're scared you know
and you're like well look you know
everybody's scared but here's what you
could miss and here's what can happen
and some people unfortunately get taken
away quicker and it's not cool so so for
me that was that was something that like
as i was coming to your show i'm like i
haven't really relived that because like
if i ever and i mean if i wrote a book i
would name it four days because the
emotions and my old having family like
my older brother
talking about busting a nut i don't know
the next time that guy jerked off i
don't know what was that
i bet he put him but he probably took
the [ __ ] plaster off that
[ __ ]
he could have been in a jackass movie
in front of that thing yeah yeah but but
you know the weird thing was when you're
in a hospital this is one thing that
that um
i think everybody goes through and
notices when you're in a hospital and
there's tubes and there's a big surgery
and there's news coming people look at
you different even your family like even
without them knowing like my mom my mom
held it together but i the fear is there
then i had siblings kind of like want to
be in and out because they didn't like
to see me like that but also they
weren't scared of death for themselves
like they see you and like they're
scared for themselves they're also like
i don't like seeing my brother like that
so like they would come in and give the
love and i'd be like i'm gonna go to the
gift shop yeah you know and just you
know and and i i saw that with some
people and then you had people come in
and be like you know you're gonna be all
right oh we'll pray or like so so it was
a lot of it was a lot of different
things but it it really was a learning
experience and it was one of the the
scariest things that i went through so
um
i know exactly what you mean i had that
gratitude moment myself i i won't i'll
spare everybody the long story again but
i'm telling you so and yeah i was 42 i
went through this crazy health scratch
kidney stones then my legs both legs
started clotting like it just kept
getting worse and worse and
my doctor's doing all these blood tests
and he's like i'm sending it to an
oncologist don't freak out i'm like i am
freaked out though this is a blood blood
cancer doctor i gotta go talk to
so i'm seeing him and he's like i don't
normally see legs both legs clotted like
this aggressively so dude homeboy gives
me his [ __ ] cell phone number for the
weekend
and i said
he goes i don't want you to be scared i
go i am i go i you just give me your
[ __ ] blood you're a blood cancer
doctor gave me your personal self told
me hit you up this weekend if i have any
problems i'm scared to leave i'm scared
to leave
oh my god and then you probably know
this it was for me when they did the
test the blood test it was a two-week
wait
so you got rushed in for an emergency
surgery so you found out for 45 days
yeah i didn't have a procedure so i
gotta wait two [ __ ] weeks and i'm
freaking the [ __ ] out for two weeks like
living life too yeah because they're
mentioning leukemia they're mentioning
lymphoma and i'm like jesus christ and
i'm trying to i'm a single dad at the
time i'm trying to get through this i
mean we had a we had a live crab feast
back in the day at the hollywood improv
with anna ferris and that day that
morning for hours i was in the hospital
and they were flushing my
fluids and trying to figure out what the
[ __ ] going on me and it took six
months and i walk in
whoa and there's this nurse
and she goes how do you feel and i said
i'm scared like i've been scared for two
weeks i don't know what everyone's about
to [ __ ] tell me i have no idea what i
what's how my life is gonna be when i
walk out of this office today wow and
she goes well i'm not supposed to tell
you but i'm gonna tell you you're good
you're fine i was like oh my god and she
goes how do you feel i just feel
a huge relief and she said let me tell
you something i'm telling you this
because every day it's my job to tell
people they have cancer
today i got to tell someone they did it
oh my god she goes you need to see that
from i'm getting chills but i just got
to chill she's like you need to see that
from my point of view and i'm telling
you now go celebrate go celebrate life
you got another chance and i was like
man i'm still that's [ __ ]
unbelievable to hear that like yeah
that's your job and every day you're
going numb to telling people you have
cancer you have cancer you're this is
where you work and today you get to tell
someone they don't she was still oh my
god dude that's like so stuff
and then since 42 to now i have put my
foot on the [ __ ] gas and was
like
[ __ ] i'm not looking back we're
living and that's it and i know what you
went through those two weeks because for
two months during that depression i
talked about the last time i was on the
show i was just going to gigs going i'm
going to be dead like in like you know
in a week like so when you're when you
those two weeks when you're living life
and you're trying to go walk around it's
always picking my daughter up
yeah
yeah am i even going to get this
what did you do what did you do when you
first walked out of the hospital did you
do any what did you do that night dude
remember did you yeah i cried when i
walked out of there i cried i got in my
car i sat down i thanked my dead father
my dad yeah
anybody i thought might have been
somewhere else [ __ ] throwing
something in i was thinking you were you
were just going yeah i was so
grateful and
that night um
i think i had my daughter that night and
i just sat with her and i had dinner
with her and that to me was celebrating
life yes you know together and then
since then i've i mean i'm still i'm
back in emdr therapy again but i always
do therapy i journal every morning and
every night
i meditate i should meditate more but i
do do it um and i do two shows about
mental health i [ __ ]
anyone that sends me a hey this is an
interesting clip or this is an
interesting especially when i'm on the
road if it's a 45 minute thing i'll sit
and listen to that you know so i'm
always trying to
look i
i'm insecure about the way i look
how i feel [ __ ] like that but the one
thing i will put to i don't go to the
gym as much as i should but i do work
here you know what i'm saying we all
want to get abs and [ __ ] everybody's
trying to look good and nobody's worried
about working up here and that's where i
really my later years it needs to be
here because and and you know look at
your success and and what i was saying
was like when my head is right my
success is you know we we're we were so
before pandemic too i was talking about
this with tom papa you were on the
hamster wheel got to do this kind of
this it's like once things slow down and
you realize like what's important it's
like no no get your head right that's it
and when your head's right your body
will get right too that's right you
watch these fat [ __ ] they're
depressed yes you know you see a dude
like i've seen it like you see a dude
that's like 450.
i remember somebody saying look at
somebody's house too look how they clean
yeah you see somebody's bedroom and you
see their living room when somebody's
immaculately clean they're just you're
just better up here because but when
it's all a mess that means you're you're
a mess if you're if you're heavy and
you're out of shape you're a mess
mentally so i totally get that man and
it's more important i mean the mentally
because once mentally everything comes
down it comes down you know that's right
yeah yeah it all sets in place and i
think a lot of people worry about i mean
look you gotta work out too obviously uh
muscle's harder to break down when you
get older and everything so it's good
for you but i think a lot of people just
go through life thinking let me work on
these biceps and these abs and [ __ ] yeah
not my trauma
not this [ __ ] incident that happened
or what's going on in my life or how can
i make this relationship better or you
know what am i bringing to the table
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] up you know i don't
think people look at that enough
especially guys like we come from an era
like your father my dad was a dudes dude
but
but i'll say this i think that i know
when my parents first split because i
would like to talk about your parents
divorce but i know when they first split
we we did a fam i remember we were young
too second grade maybe third grade going
through this and we did a family therapy
session
and i look back on that now and i think
well i know my dad was there we were all
there but i was like huh that's
so i've never been the a guy that's been
like i ain't going to therapy and
talking to some dude i've never been
that macho [ __ ] but i have been that
way about medication yeah so it's funny
like for me
i'm not the guy that's like oh you're
going to therapy but i was the guy that
was like i don't need a pill to fix this
but i remember talking to christina
pizzitzki and she's like oh i take
whatever she takes in her business and
so i went on it and it's a low dose of
10 milligram and it happened to me when
we had to [ __ ] home school
like my daughter at the time is five she
can't [ __ ] read fully she's not self
so i can't say go do your [ __ ]
and i'll check it later i have to sit
there and do school with her yeah and
dude we're in a box
losing our [ __ ] our art form goes
away like yeah
wait stand-up's gone which i'll come
back to that in a second but it made me
lose my mind i felt trapped i had no
outlet i didn't know anything to get any
of this [ __ ] out yeah um
but
going back to what was it i just said i
said i'll come back to the parents
divorce no stay like like no one ever
thought stand up would be gone oh right
right but what i did realize because we
always think i got to do this show and
this show and this [ __ ] we had no stand
up for a year and a half yeah and and
you know what
it was awful it was fine to take that
break like none of us hustlers would
ever put a self-imposed year and a half
break on our stand-up ever
ever we yeah but it happened yeah and it
was all right it was it was more than it
was needed it was fine it was needed it
was needed because we're on that hamster
even me out here i'm out here shooting
an acting project and i literally got
out here last minute i didn't have
anything booked and the reason why i
didn't have any shows booked is because
i flew in last minute open ended not
knowing when i'm flying back
exhausted with everything and even my
mind is like oh should i do shows maybe
i should do shows and i'm like whoa whoa
whoa dude whoa it's gonna be all right
it's gonna be all right like yes you
know but but our mind but pandemic let
you realize that that's right you know
um you mentioned meditation dude and i
tried it and dude i got so relaxed you
want to laugh my comedic mind is on a
lot i mean i can't it's her i the guy's
voice all i want to do is [ __ ] on the
voice oh no the woman it was just asian
yes asian was talking to me and she was
and i was going she was going like
you're fine you're relaxed and she goes
from your head to you now start with
your forehead and she went from the
forehead to the cheek bones to the
[ __ ] and i'm sitting there and it's
going great right it's going great and i
think i was fighting my wife at the time
and she's going down to your toes and
then i just pictured that voice i go
she's yelling at some dude later
i go some something some [ __ ] dude's
got jerry i'm doing a session
like i literally i was late it was funny
i'm laying in my son's room there's like
[ __ ] darth vader [ __ ] and i'm like
and i just picture her i go she's gonna
yell at some [ __ ] to go to the
grocery store or he didn't get the right
groceries and i pictured that and my
eyes open my [ __ ] eyes open and i go
i go even baby carrots god damn it
you're right you little dick
so anyway
breathe deep nose my mother hated you
from the beginning
[Laughter]
anyways you're a winner
you'd be great if you heard it anyways
in there that's a better time how
italian is that anyway so anyways i love
the ass on that though no it's funny
because
it's funny because those meditation
people have real lives and you would
think that that woman had her [ __ ]
together dude and that's always talking
like that never yells never gets upset
doesn't have anxiety
cussing out people in traffic and [ __ ]
planes going down we'll be fine you're
fine
i i try to make a rule now where my ego
only comes in the car with me you know
what i mean i try to i try to leave it
in the car for meetings and everything
else just leave it stay here we can say
whatever the [ __ ] we want with these
windows up but stay here yeah yeah well
you know you one thing that i always
liked about you and i hit it off with
you when we first met is you're the type
of dude that when i met you the first
time i knew no matter what you did in
this business you were gonna be you and
and that like th that's who i kind of
[ __ ] with like when i come out here and
a lot of comics come out to la and
they're like you gotta do this podcast
do that podcast i'm like i'm kind of
gonna [ __ ] with my friends you know like
i'm not if i'm in this business to
listen there are some podcasts that you
know you should you should do so i'm not
trying to knock that hustle but like i'm
also not gonna i'm gonna be like oh
cicla's a friend like if you come to new
york and you're like hey man like what's
up with the stand but come to the stand
you know what i mean come to the stand
or or what's going on with uh a podcast
come come you know whatever it is um
i like to do like i like that because i
feel like that's like an authentic thing
now if i meet somebody that has a or
some or if somebody that i didn't know
goes hey dude i think you're real funny
man i'd love to get you on my thing
that's different but the whole like i
gotta get in that to do that and i don't
i don't like never that no no and it's
like you said before like showing up to
a place you're not booked on and going
like hey it's like i'm not now it's like
no man i'm gonna [ __ ] with the people
that want to [ __ ] with me and i'm gonna
let my career because that's because
nobody gave a [ __ ] about me in this
business for 14 15 years and then and
then yeah then i got montreal then then
i my first special did well people like
oh that dude's funny and then this and
that and it's like i'd rather that
organic kind of come up than the other
it takes longer our way because we're
being true to ourselves and who we are
we're not coming out here to be anything
but ourselves and that road is always
always the longer one and i was told
that many years ago by friends and
mentors and i was also said like but
it's a better road it is about because
the experience is there and we've done
so much and we've been there and and
that's what it is but uh no man you're
dope your show's dope and you never
changed and and i like being around
somebody because you could see somebody
like i don't like when you see somebody
show up and they got a dope podcast but
they've been doing stand-up for six
years and then they're like i'm the
shit's like yeah you got a nice podcast
like listen
let's see you do that out
yeah
is a little different yeah selling
tickets is a different game selling
tickets is a difference getting up and
doing spots is one thing and being funny
is one thing but selling tickets in a
major u.s city is a different [ __ ]
thing yeah yeah there's a lot to being a
comic it's not just a a 15-minute spot
at the seller or the comedy store or the
improv it's can you do the 30 can you do
the hour can you go on the road can you
sell the tickets you know it's all that
[ __ ] you know it it's all that it's it's
yeah all right i want to ask you because
um my parents divorce was a a huge
pivotal thing for me in my life too and
my mom cheated on my dad and like they
tried to keep it quiet but when you're
arguing in front of the kids you know
your kids aren't done you know we're
third fourth grade we were like oh oh
mom [ __ ] somebody
somebody else oh [ __ ] yeah so what
happened with your parents divorce it
was it was as it was there was no from
what we understood by the way i'm sorry
to interrupt do you have siblings i do
okay so how many of you are there well
so my my mother and father had me and my
older brother okay and my mother and
father divorced and my mother remarried
has two two so four
you know so so there's there's four of
us two boys uh and then the youngest is
our sister
and um
so it was early eighties man my dad
my dad's like a like a tough street
smart kid but he also educated he was
educated so he like got like my father
graduated high school and then didn't go
to college for four years just like
working in restaurants doing whatever
making money bought himself a car and
then somebody's like he can never do
college and my father's like what my
father went to like university of new me
maybe university of new mexico all a's
came back home went to iowa so like he's
educated but he's also got that street
[ __ ]
but he's sicilian 100 and catholic so
divorce is
no right it's a sin it's the whole thing
italians don't do that your mother went
crazy i mean like that
so i was five my brother was ten my my
father was a big wig at aig yeah in this
in the city
and he had like a brand new 82 black
jaguar like white leather like my dad
was balling out and they got divorced
and everything just dude it was as
bitter and brutal
yelling fighting and then me and my
brother in the middle and then this
one's saying this and this one's saying
that and it wasn't really civil at all
and you know i do a joke in my act where
my dad literally is like he can't
believe or accept the divorce so he
would he called us over this line who
wanted it was it a musical my mother my
mom yeah but my father would be like hey
you know this divorce your mother did
she went crazy this divorce your mother
did
yeah
and and
and uh
yeah this divorce your mother did
and um
and and i saw so something that happened
wow here's a here's a heavy thing that i
didn't think i would talk about when my
son was born
when my son lucas was born he's 12 now
the love that i have for this little boy
had when he was a baby and then now
as as much if not just keeps growing
right but he's just he's my little boy
man and like um he's like two three and
i started to get resentful i start as i
was great my son i started to get upset
about what what was what what happened
to me and what happened to my brother i
started getting upset
and
i remember who
a lot of like i would say my dad my dad
my like my mom
not that i i can't give a pass but like
like it was just a different thing like
it was more visceral from that side but
he didn't really but my dad and i are
cool and and i i had to talk to him
because it was something where he was
like
mean i hope he'd be cool with me saying
this but it's just honest like he would
um yeah he would like
call and be like i haven't heard from
paul and i noticed that i was even
without even knowing being a little
distant
and finally i sat and i just looked him
in the face and told him when it wasn't
going to be emotional i made sure it was
going to be emotional i made sure when i
waited i made sure i was just going to
go in there and [ __ ] talk
and i just had a good talk with him and
i was like you know this was done and
like you know i was just a kid wanted to
hang on my you know hang and hang and
and you know and and when you're have
divorced parents and you're with your
mom you just want to hang out your mom
and when when you just want to hang with
your dad and it was so kind of it was so
kind of harsh
and me and my brother my older brother
christian man god bless him like he took
bullets from me man he was 10 and he
heard and saw some [ __ ] yeah he saw some
he saw plates you know flying he saw
things he saw it and i'm this little kid
who he kind of took bullets for but at
the same time like it was kind of not
cool what we went through and i think
that that you develop issues later you
know i was always i was insecure you
know i was insecure because i didn't
know
if my you know my mom was safe i would
wake up they said i'd wake up crying as
a little boy and they'd be like what's
wrong and my what i would cry about was
i think something's gonna happen to my
mom that was because there was no that
was and my stepfather was a great dude
he was around but it was just because
what what was happening with my dad
you know dad and stepfather get along no
i was gonna say you're your dad's old
school like that no the first time they
were under the same roof was 22 years
later at my wedding
is that right did they get along
no i didn't speak
they didn't speak not even a hello
not even an acknowledgement
not even an acknowledgement not even an
acknowledgement
but that's the same man your mom left
your dad for marrying she's still with
him yes and he was obviously the right
choice for her and he was um
you know with her through the cancer and
all that stuff and and i got you know
nothing but you know how was your dad
about that when you're did he shift a
little bit did he he just he he softened
up he just felt he fell for us you know
he was just like you know like i'm sorry
you have you know what i mean like he
you know uh but but yeah no so it was
like me and my brother were in the
middle of some some [ __ ] that was like
when you when you when when i think back
and i think about what was said and what
was i was exposed to what stands out
i'll give you an example i remember
laying in my my brother and i are twins
we had to share the same room my little
brother's in the room next to us and i
remember hearing my dad yell at my mama
you haven't had sex with me in six
months listen i remember that and i was
like and i'm a kid at the time i'm in
middle school and i'm like
man i'm jerking it and i'm thinking six
months and none of this holy [ __ ] yeah
yeah but i remember hearing that and i'm
like god damn and hearing them yell and
fight see what mine was not my i was too
young to hear yelling and fighting
because i was five so but it was the
visitations now now the flip side is in
my dad's defense
the courts only granted my dad eight
hours on sunday and three on wednesday
with us that's that old show so yeah
that was that old you know what the
women get that wednesday sunday [ __ ]
that was like by the book right so he
had eight hours with his boys on sunday
and three on wednesday which was only
good for what a dinner right so his
bitterness i get but it it we felt it
you know what i mean they live close by
so he always did okay yeah like he lived
close by but like yeah everybody yeah
man your mother went crazy i don't know
i don't know did he ever unfortunately
the devil invaded our family that's what
he said last night
in our family yeah that's it my whole
family tired i called my cousin and told
him yeah he was left the devil the devil
came to us what could i do and and and
and i'm [ __ ] 11. yeah so like so like
so like i'm like i live with the like so
yeah so it's like i'm living
yeah like i'm going to sleep at the
devil's crib like like
the devil bought me [ __ ] my sneakers
for school tomorrow
you know
he can't accept that he is like the
devil bought me my [ __ ] first day of
school outfit so
that's what that's what it was and and
he never remarried or anything he's
singing
he swore he never would and then how was
it when he remarried he so now my dad
right now my dad is gonna 73 so i think
he remarried what like eight years ago
oh [ __ ] yeah they say they dated for
years and years and then they went on a
cruise and got married and you know and
listen man i i i accept like my dad my
dad looked at me and said hey man i
didn't handle things you know like it
was all like it's i wanted to ask you
yeah how when you had that sit down with
him was he receptive great okay that's
good and and and i love my dad dude and
i have a lot of things that my dad has
we have the same taste in food the same
taste in certain things so like there's
a lot of him but i think my insecurity
and why and here's the other thing they
had so another big blow is we had money
my dad was a big wig at aig we lived in
a tudor in scarsdale like off of
scarsdale dude you're talking like top
[ __ ] in westchester county new york like
top [ __ ] jaguar
i remember one time we were pulling out
of the jaguar i never forget this
remember you said oh we haven't had sex
in six months you know forget i'll never
forget this because my dad loved making
people realize he was a [ __ ] baller
we're pulling out and uh there were
girls that lived across the street i
believe their names were danny and
debbie two little girls and they go
where are you going and i rolled my
dad's [ __ ] jaguar window down i go my
dad we're they're taking us to
mcdonald's my dad goes don't tell him
that [ __ ] don't tell him we're going to
mcdonald's like he didn't want he was
like oh cause that was low round yeah
yeah he's like he's going he's going
we're going to [ __ ] stay cocky
put that window up don't tell him we go
like and like
yeah he's like you know we don't we the
verses don't even make diaries what are
we [ __ ] animals they're like yeah so
he's like i remember he yo ryan he got
he got i remember specifically he got
angry he's like you don't tell me we'll
use that [ __ ] cheap burgers you know
you ain't gonna tell a man
and and uh you know so he had that thing
like i said the jaguar the whole thing
and then when that went away me and my
brother were my mom broke
we were like in a one-bedroom apartment
but she she would sacrifice
good schools in a good neighborhood to
be in a small apartment so we had a
bedroom
um
so i moved a lot a little bit after that
and that was that was tough so i had to
kind of and i think that's that's where
the comedy was where comedy kind of
developed for me because i was be able
to kind of fit in anywhere through jokes
and stories and they'd be like oh let
paul watch so when i saw eddie do raw
and i and and i would imitate it and
people watch paul do this or watch paul
do that and i was telling tom pop on his
podcast too i said my grandfather died i
was joking at the wake i'm like seven
so i would deal with horrible things
like that so i think when my mother
would move me and it would be and i
would like i would get popular girls
would like me i play sports i was like
one of the kid and then all of a sudden
i heard my i'm gonna move and then i
would be like low totem pole and it
would hurt my hurt so what would happen
is i would have to get friends but then
when they met me
i think the comedy and i think the way
that my get my talent after my gift was
was my gift was to be able to make
somebody and and i knew i had it because
a lot of older kids liked me because
older kids found me to be funny they're
like oh this kid watch this [ __ ] so that
was my that was kind of my way and now
looking back i know why i do what i do
you know had my parents stayed in that
tutor in scarsdale and then me and my
brother go to these big so my brother
went to bu he went to a good school but
had i not been distracted i would maybe
have some [ __ ] sales job went to
college got a degree do something so
i'll never look back and say i love
everything you know it has to go that
way
yeah all the bad [ __ ] had to do it had
to play out exactly how it did for you
to sit right there right now and and and
that's that's that's the amazing thing
and that's why i'm i'm a very big
believer in in that destiny i'm very big
believer and i'll take this [ __ ] all the
way back full circle is i believe i'm
not saying it's because of this but i i
remember when i had that talk where i
said with whatever god i remember going
look
get me through this and i'm gonna make
the most of this yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna bulldoze through that
door and i'm gonna do things so then
years later you know i got to be honest
with you i was i was sitting on this
movie and i see all these people i'm not
really allowed to talk about it but and
i remember sitting there monday i flew
in sunday i'm sitting there monday and
i'm looking around and i remembered that
kid i was i remember that kid that i was
and i'm going i'm sitting on a [ __ ]
i'm doing this i'm doing it and and i
got a special that's going to be on a
major platform and it's my second and
all of these peers that are amazing and
these people
are saying dude man it's it's great and
wait for this thing to pop off and and
i'm i'm literally going i was that kid
who just was moving and i was the kid
who who you know was just like oh man i
hope every teachers would tell my mom
man i hope he'll be all right people
going hey we're kind of worried about
him because you know the drinking and
the party and all the stuff that i was
doing was to to to you know be attention
and and and to be the party and i wanted
a good time because like i felt like
there was no stability anywhere else so
let this party and friends be the
stability and and and but i found
something and i was able to get to this
this place and listen i have a lot of
work to do i got to go further and
further but you nurtured it that's the
thing hey yeah it's [ __ ] nurtured
it's amazing that skill and now you're
making other people feel good about
their [ __ ] because we all have it
man we all have it we all have it yeah
this is a great i know we got to get you
out of here this was a great [ __ ]
episode you got to catch a flight thank
you oh dude thank you for [ __ ] making
time i'll be honest with you this was
one of my favorite things that i did all
week when i was here and i [ __ ] acted
so i just loved talking to you and um
yeah so you brought it out of me again
because i didn't get to relive those
days as as detailed but um thank you for
having me and uh anybody listening to
this man if you want to see uh check me
out i'll be in uh
tampa uh may was it fifth sixth seventh
uh i'm gonna be in buffalo helium may
26th i'm going to i'll be at san diego
comedy company uh end of june and more
dates are being added go to
paulversie.com please uh like subscribe
the versi effect podcast it's growing i
got a studio now in new york also
anything better that i co-host with bill
burr and uh thank you
anybody who who likes this and
subscribes to my youtube channel all
that and get me on social media follow
me at paul versi that's
v-i-r-z-i i had a blast yeah and check
out paul's last episode here on the
honeydew as always ryan sickler.com ryan
sickler on all social media we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you